yeah today my colleague arpad eric has
managed to master an agreement on
wholesale roaming charges and presented
a sizable progress on parcel delivery
zevallos kampala the agreement of today
give us a mandate to start negotiations
with european parliament and to achieve
the objective of abolishing roaming
surcharges as the 15th of june 2017 item
origins of today to review of the
regulatory framework electronic
communication so-called gigabyte which
will be society we can state that most
of the minister's support it the
objective of having better access many
of them stated that it goes hand in hand
with competition and consumers
protection we are pleased to present a
partial general approach today on a
Wi-Fi for Europe proposal from the
Commission but have to say really in
just two months since the presentation
certainly this is only a start and it
will not equip every city or town in
Europe but it way create an investment
cycle and the trustworthy Wi-Fi for
Europe quality trademark I'm are also
happier because of the fact that we can
start with relax about 700 megahertz
which is extremely important for 5g I'm
very grateful for this broad support we
we cut practically from all the member
states to act immediately to start
whether with a communication and and
then legal action server to a low free
data flows across the European Union